yo what's up everybody this is
international master Daniel wrench with
chess comm and today we're here for
another two-minute drill let's learn how
to play the root Lopes white starts with
the move one e4 the most common move in
the history of chess and after blacks
most common response e5 white
immediately begins putting pressure on
the center black naturally develops a
piece which also depends upon and
immediately after the move Bishop e5 we
have reached the reuleaux PES with a
Spanish game as it's also known the idea
is very simple white is not only
threatening the knight here but by
attacking this piece white is also
indirectly increasing his pressure on
the dark Spurs in the center
particularly the e5 pawn black can
respond with counter playing the opening
and often should with the move a6 the
idea being that white is not able to
eliminate the knight immediately with
the idea of winning the pawn as black
will simply win this pawn back with
check and equalize or have an advantage
in the center
therefore white retreats the bishop and
after the move Knight f6 continuing
counter attacking ideas white castles
black doesn't risk capturing this pawn
too early as it opens up the center and
often creates issues for the King so
after the move Bishop e7 white needs to
officially defend this pawn therefore
this pawn is defended now black also
needs to defend the e5 pawn the best way
to do so is the move b5 and after Bishop
e3 castles we have nearly reached the
main line to go in defense of the
reuleaux PES here white these days will
often play the move at h3 as a means to
prevent the marshal attack which is
another video here in our two-minute
drill selection on our youtube channel
if white plays c3 instead of the move h3
black and knighted play the marshal
which again you can check that out in
our library here or continue with
mainline ideas with the move d6
defending the e5 pawn white wants to
expand in the center and increase his
space but before doing so needs to
prevent the move Bishop c4 h3 is played
and after 95 Bishop c2 c5 and d4 both
sides have naturally expanded and
develop their pieces and here are the
critical ideas for the future of this
position for white art to develop and
maneuver this knight around heading to
one of these two squares not only with
access to these weak light squares but
also hoping for a potential attack
against blacks King often black's idea
is to simply complete development and
either build on the tension here in the
center hoping for white to sort of break
and either either capture on e5 or c5 or
at some point expand on the queenside
with an attack hope you enjoyed this
video and I'll see you around on chess
calm